[Music]
hey y'all it's matinee 54 yeah James got
a screwdriver and I got eggnog with rum
whoo we're getting all seasonal lunch oh
well I'm not you foreigners don't know
what eggnog is Horace boys don't have
eggnog do you guys don't know what
eggnog is it's kind of like melted ice
cream kind of like a melted with Rome in
it yeah I have to put the ROM in it but
I can't have any other way kinda like
melted vanilla ice cream with with like
it's light and nutmeg flavor it's good I
can only drink it in small doses oh
because it's a little super high-calorie
well yeah it's all eggs and all sugar
well that's what makes it good but you
know like I said I can't really get away
with that kind of everyone cup up for
every one cup of milk
that's in there I think there's two eggs
good lord
and like a half a cup of sugar just like
that but sugar like drinking an entire
pie yeah pie filling not that I wouldn't
do that well I guess that's it almost
it's almost kind of like eating cookie
dough okay I've done that one yeah also
when I was a little kid I used to eat
six of butter yeah when I was really
little I was skinny when I was a kid but
yeah so all right so this week on our
met nation we're seeing we're doing all
new stuff like we usually do however we
did not bother to get off our lazy asses
and go to the theater this week because
there wasn't I think the only new thing
that started this week was Jim Jim and I
man and I was like well that's I'm like
I could suck and relieve it off right
it's like maybe we could go see it next
week if there's nothing else so I just
said look there was like enough new [ __ ]
this week that we didn't really have to
go to the movie theater
Hollywood's blowing it blows well
there's some good [ __ ] coming out there
there's like some new horror movies
coming out it's just like a few more
weeks that okay weird every year so far
with our experience wasn't on the AMC
a-list see and all this [ __ ] the theater
every year there's like maybe five good
movies maybe six yeah but I think that's
that's been true forever yeah
I mean every now and then there's like a
year the where there's like a you know
an unusual amount of really good ones
but I mean when I'm looking back at
years I can only think of like a handful
of good movies every year and then the
rest from artists like Joker was pretty
incredible that's one of the better ones
of the year so you know like I said so
we didn't go to the [ __ ] theater and
then we just ended up seeing one on
Netflix and a couple on shutter so as I
mentioned last week we are going to be
reviewing each new episode of the 2019
creep show series that is on shudder
shudder original series and like I said
we're gonna be a little bit behind
because they premiere like you know the
night at the same night that we like
record the show so we're gonna be like
one week behind so this week we're doing
episode two now this one again has two
stories as all the episodes are going to
have the first one this one was a
werewolf slash Nazi story called bad
wolf down yeah Jeffrey Combs in it
starring Jeffrey Combs yes a Nazi yeah I
think it's an SS you I think he's played
in not zero yeah he was like a SS
commander it's pretty cartoonish it's a
good one though it's just like a real
short like almost like it's a little
short our Twilight Zone episode real
well duh a lot of werewolf action a lot
of shooting and you know that's pretty
cool this one reminded me more visually
it seemed very much like the segments
from the original Creepshow movie
because they really seem to like go all
out with like you know with like the
bright lights behind and Leia patterns
and [ __ ] like that another thing that I
kind of love about this like I said you
can say because obviously this isn't
like a super high budget series or
anything but yeah it does good job I
really liked like the ways they work
around that like when they do a werewolf
transformation that was cool in this
it's like they have the guy and then
they do like a comic book pages yet
hoping they were really Fagin he and yes
he's like transforming into a world so
you know it's like oh that was super
clever
you see transformation in Cortana and
he's done boom and it's good practical
effects so the werewolves look pretty
cool
I didn't all the werewolves look kind of
different from each other yeah which I
guess that was kind of I don't know if
they just did that because they just
were like well we just want to make it a
whole bunch of different kind of
werewolves or because they figured that
you know it maybe everybody had their
own werewolf look when you're when
everybody gets turned into a werewolf it
has like one look like from what I
remember some of it looked like
something out of howling and some of it
look like werewolf in london and yeah
there was some definitely like callbacks
to that there's a lot of like easter
eggs in this not only to like Stephen
King shed and everything but there's a
lot of Easter eggs and I'll mention one
of the next in the next segment too but
you know that it kind of gave me a
little bit because the whole story of it
like I said it's very short it was
actually written and directed by a guy
named Rob schrab
or SH Rob he was the co-writer on
Monster House which a lot of people
really liked he was a co-creator of the
Sarah Silverman program and one thing
that I only found out when I looked his
ass up he is the co-director on the new
mst3k okay series that's on Netflix and
so there you go yeah so that's the same
guy that's doing this like I said it's a
very simple story it's not like super
surprise or anything like that it's just
like a group of American GIs they waste
a bunch of Nazis yeah what I've said
Nazis is like the very Aryan looking son
of Jeffrey Combs Jeffrey Combs gets
pissed off about it the GIS are hiding
out in this old abandoned I guess it's
an abandoned police station yeah and
there's a woman in one of the cells in
there who is a werewolf yes and then the
you know the GI is to get surrounded by
Nazis in the oh [ __ ] what are we gonna
do we're going to get killed because
there's only three or four of them and
they were super outnumbered yeah and I
won't spoil what have you don't spoil it
it's not like a super super like you see
it coming but it's a it's an
action-packed episode yeah it's just
action it's not real heavy in story it's
just cool action and like I said I like
that it really if of all the segments
that they've done so far this seemed to
lean the most into the cheesy the camp
factor it leans the most intellect the
visuals from the original movie with
like you know the the really saturated
bright colors behind and like you know
people like isolated against these like
bright red
like backgrounds the only comic-book
style oh yeah then that's definitely the
one you know that's been closest to that
so over-the-top acting over-the-top
noxee actions just everything was over
yeah like I said it was just like real
campy and cheesy and it seemed to just
be having a good you know good fun with
it you know the Nazis getting their
heads knocked off and [ __ ] like that so
it was pretty rad one guy getting blown
up and [ __ ] like yes there's some good
goer there now the second segment was
called the finger this was directed by
Greg Nicotero and based on a story by
David J scow he was obviously a very
famous horror writer he also worked on
like some cheesy movies from the
eighties and nineties like I think he
worked on the critters movies or
something but yeah this one was actually
kind of a strange one but I ended up
really liking it DJ Qualls was in this I
guess he's been like on supernatural and
I think he was in like a lot of those
kind of late teen early 20s kind of
movies for a few years back like road
trip and stuff like that like he always
kind of plays kind of a dorky kind of
kid and he's super cute in this so the
whole premise of it is that he is this
lonely man with you know and he's got
like bill collectors calling all the
time and he doesn't have any friends and
all this other kind of [ __ ] and one of
the things that he likes to do is kind
of just walk around the neighborhood at
night and look for objects like he's I
guess he's like a hoarder or something
like that and like he just likes to go
around and find things well one night
he's walking around his neighborhood and
he finds a finger and it's not a human
finger it's just like this really weird
spindle II finger with like kind of a
big long cloth and kind of looks like
maybe like a witch finger or something
like that so he's like huh that's very
interesting so he takes it home and puts
it in this freezer only to discover that
this finger is slowly starting to grow
an organism like its there was another
finger grows and then it hangers and a
whole arm grows and then a whole little
creature grows yeah and he names this
creature Bob that's pretty cool it kind
of looks like that little alien out of
the out of alien 3 yeah or it looks like
a little tiny Oni Pumpkinhead
like a punk ahead bone eating a long
time you know the movie Pumpkinhead it
looks like a little bitty one of those
it's a little cuter yeah like you
doesn't really have any eyes he looks a
little bit like a xenomorph tiny little
bit and eat but they'll he's kind of
like baiji colored prob about four feet
tall I think maybe three yeah and like
he kind of runs around and stuff
now this one um it's kind of a weird
story in the Creepshow universe I guess
just because I can't really think of
another one where I mean because the the
character played by DJ Qualls I think
his name is Clarke he breaks the fourth
wall a lot like he seems like he's
talking directly to the audience and
like kind of making these and then you
know you know so it's very like you know
cops come to the door and then like he's
talking to the cops and he closes the
door talks to us for a second and then
he opens the door back up and it seems
like no time has passed and stuff so
there's like an ironic thing and I could
see how that would kind of go awry but
actually I thought it was kind of
charming
and I also really liked this kind of
[ __ ] up relationship that developed
between Clarke and Bob like this little
critter I'm not gonna say like what
bobbins of doing but the Bob as a little
creature was like super cute um I feel
like most of it was practical effects
like I said because Greg Nicotero
directed this and he's super into that
now when it like moved around the
apartment like sometimes it looked like
very obvious CGI but it didn't really
bother me or anything like that this I
have to say this episode was pretty good
I still haven't seen a segment that I
like as much as the house of the head
from the first one but we're only four
segments in yeah the new one didn't it
the third episodes out already just went
up today yeah it just went up like an
hour before we have greenness so we're
gonna like watch it later on tonight and
we'll review that one next week but so
far I'm like digging the show there's
like you know a lot of good [ __ ] on here
on this show I think I probably slightly
preferred the finger just because it was
a little more unusual like instructure
to some of the other stories that they
do and I really liked the creature he
was like kind of cute and horrific and I
like that I like that the series has
variety in it so that's one of the best
things about it I think it's like well
and with the nice thing about
anthologies and I think one of the
reasons why I like them so much is that
you know they're just kind of like
bite-sized yes it's like even if you see
one that you're like
men and really like that then the next
one might be like super awesome and none
of these stories are ponderous you know
I mean take a long time they're short to
the point they're even faster than a
damn old Twilight Zone episode yeah like
I said they're only 15 or 20 minutes
long so they don't like [ __ ] around you
know the the premises the premises of
them are kept fairly simple on the you
know it's so far
yeah they don't get super complicated
not saying that like some of the ones
you know down the line might not be like
that but I really do like and I kind of
like and I don't know if they're gonna
do this on every one but I kind of like
how they're taking two really
contrasting styles of story and putting
them together in one episode because
remember we were talking about the first
one where they had kind of this like
creepy psychological horror that didn't
really have any gore and then they had
like this you know this other one that
was a lot different than that and I feel
like they did that on this one as well
like that a really cheesy can't be
werewolf story and then just kind of
like a more weird dark humor type of
story with like you know what I mean
though it's a good series I'm glad to
shut that shutter got it
I mean shuddered as the money was well
spent he asked me yeah I think so too
and like I said it looks like you know
it looks like they've got like a really
lot of heavy hitters on all-star cast
you know and stuff like that so you know
they got [ __ ] Jeffrey Combs man
Jeffrey Thompson even though he's only
in it for like a few minutes but still
it's Jeffrey [ __ ] Combs yeah that
looks good too yeah he really does he
doesn't actually look that much
different that much different the last
movie that we saw him in his age what
was that was it beyond reanimate or
something like that yeah I was the one
at the pretty one of those weird
whatever it was it was a long time ago
anyway but yeah so episode 2 is
streaming now and also they just put
three up but there we're not gonna do
that one yet so go check it out
you
in the next movie we watched this week
was the highly anticipated Netflix
original in the tall grass based on the
short story by Stephen King and Joe Hill
who was Stephen King's son and a
novelist in his own right in case you
didn't know so I had actually been
looking forward to this for a very long
time
you know Netflix has been doing pretty
[ __ ] awesome with the Stephen King
adaptations particularly Gerald's game
in 1922 which was also very good this
one I hadn't read the source material
prior to seeing it although I did read
it afterward and if you want to read it
it's not very long it's you know it's on
the Esquires website or at least it is
as of today um so you can go and read it
for free if you're into that because I
was curious to see how it differed from
the source material and it does like
kind of drastically so the set up of
this it was actually directed by
vincenzo natali and probably best known
for doing like splice and cube yeah he
also did one that I feel like doesn't
get mentioned a lot when people talk
about him but it's called hunter um it I
don't know I think I saw on Hulu or
maybe it was on Netflix a long time ago
or something like that and I really
really liked that movie it was kind of
like a weird time loop movie and I feel
like it doesn't really get talked about
when people talk about him but you know
if you want to see it it's a you know
it's quite good called Haunter but yeah
so this movie okay so it deals with a
brother and sister Becky and Cal and
they are driving to San Diego I believe
now she's like six months pregnant I
guess the boyfriend has like [ __ ] off
because he didn't want he doesn't want
to marry her he doesn't want to be a dad
blah-dee-blah so she is going to San
Diego to kind of like an arranged and
adoption or decide what she's going to
do like when the baby comes or whatever
so they're driving through I think it's
Kansas even though this was shot in
Ontario Canada actually so they're
driving through Kansas and they have to
stop the car for her to throw up because
it's pregnant and while their stops they
hear a little boy in the very tall grass
next
the road calling for help now that's
pretty weird enough but then a few
minutes later when they decide that
they're gonna go in there and look for
this poor little kid they hear a woman's
woman's voice telling the kid not to
tell them to come into the grass right
and like don't make anybody else come in
here and the reason for this will soon
become apparent because Becky and Cal
actually do go in there to help this
little kid whose name turns out to be
Tobin and the taught the titular tall
grass is they never explain exactly what
it is but the creepy thing about this
has like a really good concept and like
a really good set up like the first 30
minutes are just kind of like super
freaky because you can think about what
would it be like if you're driving
through like butt [ __ ] nowhere and you
stop and like some kid it's like cotton
like in the middle of a corn maze or
something like that which is the thing
that happened because of cabins because
I've heard about people getting lost in
that [ __ ] you go in there to help him
and then all of a sudden so Becky and
Cal get separated and then they're
trying to find each other it's like it
sounds like they're right there but then
they come to there's nobody there and
then suddenly they you know it sounds
like then they're left and then suddenly
they on the right and then they're like
trying to find each other and they can't
do it and it seems like they're getting
farther and farther from the road and
they can't figure out why because
they're not moving it's like there's
this one great scene where you know he
says well why don't you jump up you know
so I can see because the grass is like
seven or eight feet tall and it's like
put your hands up in the air and we'll
see where we are so we can you know find
out where we are
so they both jump up and they're only
like 10 15 feet apart and they're like
oh all right like now don't do it again
and now she's way the [ __ ] over there
you know I mean like it's only a few
seconds later so there's like that whole
creepy aspect and that comes pretty much
straight from the story where there's
like this weird where it seems like it's
making people move around and like a
space war like a space warp type of
thing now one thing that was added for
the movie though was the time loop angle
which as far as I could determine you
know unless I didn't read it right this
didn't really have anything to do with
the story because what ends up happening
and like I said I'm not gonna spoil it
but what ends up happening is that
they keep running into people and then
sometimes they'll find like somebody and
you think they're dead like they die but
then later on they're alive again
because there's like several different
timelines going on at once
right so it's just like this whole
[ __ ] time loop thing going on and
it's like super vine [ __ ] and you
really have to like watch it a couple of
times so like get what's going on I
think also there might be some kind of
thing where I mean like I said it
doesn't really smack you over the head
with it but I do think there is some
kind of like metaphorical thing about
you know everybody trying to like sort
out their problems you know what I mean
like they're kind of like lost in this
wilderness until they you know figure
out their issues so I think there's a
little bit of that but you don't have to
like read that into it if you don't want
to I should say that Patrick Wilson is
in this and like I said everybody knows
her from the conjuring movies he was in
bone tomahawk and stuff like that he
makes a really really good villain I
don't think I've ever seen him playing a
villain before I'm sure he has but I
don't think I've ever seen him playing
one and he plays a really really good
psycho in this he plays Ross who was
like the dad of the little kid because
there's like a whole family and a dog in
there and everything there's all kind of
and all kind of like there's like some
weird creepy [ __ ] because I should say
that even though there's really no
explanation for what the tall grass is
it seems like it's some kind of you know
it's like a field that's generated
apparently I guess by this [ __ ] rock
that's in the middle that has like all
these like weird petroglyphs on it and
stuff so I feel like in essence this is
kind of like a a mixture of children of
the corn meets the Tommyknockers it kind
of that's look out of the vibe that I
got yeah I will say like I said now I
liked a lot of the Netflix Stephen King
adaptations I haven't seen the show
Castle Rock because I don't have Hulu
but I've heard that that's really
excellent so I'm gonna check that out as
well they're adapting everything single
[ __ ] and Stephen King thing this year
I swear to god I don't remember it I
fell asleep you I think you were doing
something else or you might have been
like out in a gym or something like that
yeah that sidetracked Aaron yeah you
were out cooking or honorable you don't
but yeah so um like I said I think I
liked
the setup of this more than I feel like
it went slightly off the rails like as
it went out like not super operating
though but yeah it's like so in a way
like I kind of liked the way that the
director tied it up because that's not
the way the story was tied up I think
the story look was left much more
ambiguous this is kind of ambiguous too
but you get more of a sense of like a
total narrative because you get like you
know you get the idea of like a closure
like the circle coming to an end like
you know what I made at the end of it
which the short story didn't really have
like it was just kind of left open-ended
like I said I didn't like I didn't think
this was as good as Gerald's game or
1922 but it is for sure worth watching
it seems like it's getting sort of so-so
reviews like kind of mixed most people
saying you know it's a cool concept that
they didn't really do enough with or
they didn't explain or do they explain
too much or you know what I mean it's
like everybody has their different
depending about it but um I would
actually I would probably watch it a
second time just because I feel like
there was a lot of [ __ ] going on in
there that I missed because like I said
any of these tech kind of time loop
things you have to watch more than once
because there's all kind of [ __ ] going
on in there that's uh that I didn't
really don't really get the first time
and then you have to like think about it
so but it's definitely worth watching
especially if you're a Stephen King fan
like I said the the short story by
Stephen King and Joe Hill is far as I
know I was still available on Esquires
website you can read it for two for free
it's in two parts so go check it out
it's quite different than the movie
similar set up but it doesn't really go
to the same place oh I forgot to mention
when we were talking about Creepshow on
the last segment I mentioned earlier on
that this and oh that was like an easter
egg in the second segment and then I
forgot to mention what it was
now I actually didn't notice it but I
saw another reviewer pointed out so I
went back and looked it up in the second
segment when he opens the freezer where
his little alien buddy or whatever it is
where Bob sleeps in the freezer there is
a there is a container of the stuff from
the Larry Cohen movie huh and it's all
like frozen and iced over and stuff so I
thought that was pretty cute I'm like oh
that's okay through that bit there so
Easter eggs alright no 140 would get
that probably not although the stuff I
think this stuff is on shudder at the
moment as well because I just read
watched it the other day and I was like
ah I forgot how fun that movie oh yeah
so in the tall grass on Netflix check it
out
you
okay and the third movie we watched this
week was one that I hadn't heard
anything about prior to it just dropped
on shudder yep and I decided to watch it
as I said what the hell it came out this
year it looks alright
is this a shutter exclusive I believe it
is it did do the rounds of some
festivals but you know earlier this year
but then shutter picked it up and as far
as I know it's a shutter exclus this is
another one of those movies where it
shows up and and it's Australian movie
and it's like shut the [ __ ] up we're
gonna show you how to make a movie just
like Mad Max yeah Mad Max just shows up
and throws a dynamite item and walks
away from the explosion and emotion and
it goes that's how you make a movie ah
the Australians they don't do a whole
lot but when they do do something they
do this [ __ ] right they do man yeah they
all make awesome movies you got an
awesome [ __ ] bezel look the bridge a
party there from Australia yeah Nick
Cave man they had some cool [ __ ] back in
the 70s and 80s you know parallel
universe Ford cars that you like to xB
Falcon you know [ __ ] that are still
legendary over here you know you guys do
cool [ __ ] if you guys do [ __ ] your own
way which I like this is a movie that's
in that same vein where it's a horror
movie but it's it's all action and you
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on and
then when you do find out what's going
on you oh man some weird [ __ ] it's got
some really good practical effects from
what I saw look everything was practical
what as far as I know yes
and just some cruel [ __ ] happens it's
not like on the level of saw I would say
it's torture porn but is pushing it it's
more like imagine Friday the 13th one
and two and and Halloween but like on
roids and a modern version of that this
is very much like a modern version of
the old classics there's some great
[ __ ] door in this yeah we miss do not
watch this because it will give it it
will [ __ ] you up yeah great movie I'm
only [ __ ] gory and I like it because
they kept the story very elemental they
didn't try to be too clever with [ __ ]
it's
pretty simple and just kicks ass it just
it brings its own guns to the fight yeah
we didn't even mention this is called
the Furies called the Furies yeah and I
believe this is the directorial debut of
a person named Tony de Chino
okay was it Tony shows up and goes shut
the [ __ ] up man this is how you make us
out there this is how you make a movie I
really did love this baby
yes [ __ ] cool movies it's like well
here's the thing it's it's a very lean
82 minutes
um it's basically straight up survival
horror a little bit like it kind of like
most dangerous game type of hunting
humans for sport type of thing yeah um
basically what happens you get like a
very short you know kind of an opening
sequence with your main character whose
name is Kayla and she we establishes
epilepsy she has a best friend whose
name is Maddy they kind of have an
argument in the street one night while
they're out [ __ ] around and then
subsequently Maddie gets kidnapped and
then Kayla blacks out now when Kayla
wakes up she is in essentially like a
big steel coffin thing it's like a big
box and like spray-painted on the top it
says Beauty six yeah and as soon as she
comes out she starts wondering if she's
like in the middle of this [ __ ] I
think it's like a eucalyptus forest
forest the locations they used are all
real they didn't make anything up or
nothing like that it was like there's a
eucalyptus forest and even later on in
the movie where they go into like that
little where all the little cabins and
like ruined cabins and [ __ ] are that's
an actual old gold mine that used to be
there so they just kind of like used it
just the way it was and so she shortly
begins to discover because she's running
around trying to figure out where the
[ __ ] she is there's a really great shot
where they do like a kind of a drone
shot where it just goes up and up and up
and you see this forest just goes on and
on and on forever and then like out
outside of it it's just like [ __ ]
desert just like you like an outback so
there's nowhere for her to go there's a
lot to this movie that reminded me of
predators which is like predator 3 where
people wake up and they're on it and
then they realized that they're on
another
and they're being haunted yeah similar
said often and it reminded me very much
of that and I'm saying go with that
that's that's a good premise take that
but there's also kind of like like Jason
style slashers and more like my leather
feel and my and Michael Myers and
Leatherface wearing people skin yeah and
then there's more happens but it can't
spoil it you just gotta watch it it's
you know I mean I there's more to
there's more to it yeah I mean you'll
find out what's going on like I said if
I'm not pretty quick it's not a super
original premise but the way that it's
set up and the way it's pulled out like
really keeps you invested because not
just her I mean is she's running around
trying to figure out what the [ __ ] she
is and what the [ __ ] is going on and
where the [ __ ] Maddie went because she
saw Maddie get grabbed before she
blacked out also you know she meets
these other women run around in the
woods and it's like so there's all this
other condition then she sees these big
dudes that are like wearing skin and
like carrying [ __ ] machetes and axes
and [ __ ] like that and you know and run
from and everything so like I said it's
very but basically just straight up a
survival horror but they're just trying
to you know get away from these beasts
as they call them and they're trying to
like keep the other she's trying to keep
like the other girls like trying to find
out which ones want to [ __ ] me over
because there's all this it there's all
these rules you know what I mean that
she finds out like as the game goes on
yeah you know so certain things happen
when certain people die and things like
that so it's like very strategic if you
thought predators or yeah or three you
will like this movie yeah and like I
said it's and I and actually that's my
second favorite predator movie I like
predator wanna like I liked it a lot to
its it was like way better than it had
any right to be yeah people didn't like
predator 3 I think when it came out that
much but it aged really well that that
was I like that movie I like that better
much better in predator 2 yeah and
president what predator for yeah okay oh
yeah that was yeah um but yeah so this
is like a really great like I said it
just it did some festivals and it's like
I don't even think it got and you have
theatrical release up to any great
extent not new you
anyway and then shudders was just kind
of like hey check this out and I was
like oh okay I will and then I was a man
that kicked ass and like I said if you
are squeamish you might want to avoid it
because there are some there's some
nasty [ __ ] [ __ ] in this I mean
there was one scene in particular and
you know you know me I'm something you
know I'm like go around I can watch her
there's anything but there was a couple
scenes in this where I was like [ __ ]
yeah
special effects a really good direction
was really good score was good acting
was very good yeah yeah just a great
[ __ ] horror movie it's like you know
anyway above its weight oh yeah I don't
think they spent a whole lot on that
movie but you can't really tell if it is
I'm not sure like I am DB said seven
million but I don't think that they
because the thing about it is that if
there's not a lot of information about
the movie ahead of time because I've
heard about ones where IMDB said that it
costs X million dollars and then like
the filmmakers came out and said no it
costs more like six hundred thousand
dollars right um you know I mean so this
might have cost considerably less to
make than seven million but you can't
really tell like I said the practical
effects in this are really good yeah I
mean the one scene in particular that
thing you have that involves an axe yeah
an action and girls face it it looked
super mystic you know I mean it's like
[ __ ] with eyeballs there's like all
kinds of [ __ ] but yeah like props to the
[ __ ] special effects team because you
guys did an amazing job
also cinematography is very nice the
very nice use of like location and stuff
like that I think the forest that they
filmed it in was outside kambera
somewhere yeah and this movie's
absolutely merciless it is yeah so just
Gary you get ready like I said it's
really good and if you really like
survival horror game style horror remind
yourself it's just a movie yeah there's
a plan it's not real yeah but yeah
seriously it's on shudder right now shut
our exclusive as far as I know it's
called the Furies and you should
definitely tell yet highly highly
recommended we don't work for shudder
but they got a lot of guys on top shitty
movies that follow me on Facebook on
Tom's shitty movie they're joining up
with shudder shudder I like shudder
better than that
exit forest I do as well yeah I mean I
would kill Netflix I would cut Netflix
off if it wasn't for MST 3000 and a
couple of those little series I like
those um I like those like true-crime
docu-series that they do like they did
one about the outcasts or murderers they
do it about my 5 bucks a month or you
you can actually get it down to like 4
dollars and 20 cents a month I paid 56
for a year that's like four dollars I
think that's four dollars and forty
seven cents a month that works yeah it's
actually punching way above its weight
it will Hammer horror films on there a
bunch of politically incorrect [ __ ] on
there class when they ads all stuff all
the time it's all like blu-ray quality
yeah Hammer horror [ __ ] titty fests
and [ __ ] they got it all along yeah they
just added three documentaries and stuff
and pretty cool and like I said series
actually I think not only did they just
add the New York show rape show episode
they also I think they just net now
added a new series our new season of
channel zero which is a really good
anthology show it's well it's not an
anthology necessarily it's each season
is based on a different creepypasta okay
um so I saw like the first three seasons
and I really really liked him I don't
even remember what channel that [ __ ] was
on originally maybe sci-fi I don't know
yeah I don't watch regular TV but um but
yeah so that's another thing that I'm
gonna have to watch later maybe we can
review that next week yeah a season of
channels here yeah but out of all these
little services that we have I think
[ __ ] I'd rather I think I like share
the best well that was the one if I can
only have one that's the one
because I mean you know if you have that
as your pacing and then to be honest
there's stuff like to be and voodoo and
stuff like that they have so many horror
movies for free that it's like you know
what I mean the thing is is that there's
commercials and interruptions and stuff
it's actually not as many I'm in
particularly to be it's not as witchy on
my on my smart TV I can why well I can
watch it on my laptop just fine and I
don't have any problems and honestly the
commercials there's maybe one every half
an hour yeah to be just it was
problematic on my TV but they have a
[ __ ] on them style I just for them for
that [ __ ] five dollars a month you
just can't be shudder yeah and it did
that app the way it works on my
Smart TVs just perfect yeah we've never
had a Rob with it yeah we don't really
have prob but yeah and like I want to
give they have a lot of exclusive to
they tend to get their grubby little
fingers on a lot of like kind of
festival darlings and you like that
which I think was the case with the
Furies which I think it's cool that
they're willing to go out there and
snatch up like ones that did really well
at festivals but might not get a
theatrical release because I want to see
that show yeah and the old classics like
from the 70s and the 80s that you just
won't find any more on Netflix I was
gonna say and it's like I never did
review it because it fell into what's
not old enough for the retrospective and
it wasn't new enough for the matinee
show but they had one on there that came
out I think in 2016 2017 called the love
which and if you guys anybody that
really likes like this old-school like
jell-o movies check that [ __ ] out
oh yeah yeah oh yeah that was a
beautiful looking movie it looked like
just like an old giallo movie like the
woman in the movies yeah it was she
wanted to make it look exactly like a
movie from back then and yeah and it was
like super super cool it was like weird
it wasn't really was like this weird I
guess it was kind of a horror movie but
it was like more like a weird horror
romance thing kind of it was just very
bizarre but I really liked it and it was
especially like just so just looking at
it I was just like oh this is like so
cool-looking
but yeah so seriously the furies 2019
and oz Blois tation movies yes follow
them along with that one and like I said
if you love survival horror if you love
gore
I'll show you movies if you were stuck
check that check that [ __ ] out it's
really really good what what yeah
alright what are you talking about
you